hey youtubers is charlie I hope you guys
had an awesome Doctor Who week I know I
did I hope you're all recovering from
the fantasms if you didn't see it the
BBC just posted a teaser for the
Christmas special and since we now know
some things about what the story is
going to be as well as some things about
series 8 I thought it'd be fun to do an
early review so I'm going to be doing my
top five things to look forward in the
Christmas special as well as some things
in series 8 i'm also going to be doing a
video for all the easter eggs and the
50th anniversary special this week so be
sure to subscribe to get that too so
here we go top five things to look
forward to in the Christmas special
number 5 Prix series 7 trenzalore so if
you thought the doctor is going to be
landing on trenzalore before the war
that killed him so as you can see we
have a behind the scenes image that
shows green that means that things are
not dead yet obviously when we visited
trends Lord during series 7 during the
name of the doctor everything was dead
it was basically like a graveyard giant
graveyard for the whole planet so this
means that we'll be visiting trenzalore
before that happened and for those that
are confused trenzalore is just the
final graveyard of the doctor it's not
going to be the graveyard of the
eleventh Doctor so however many more
years the BBC continues to make Doctor
Who that final doctor that will be his
graveyard unless they change things like
they did with the time war during the
50th anniversary episode number four
Monster Mash so they're going to be four
different types of Doctor Who villains
very iconic villains in the episode at
the same time this has never happened
before they'll be the silence as you can
see silence will fall Daleks Cybermen
and weeping angels it's unclear as to
whether or not they'll all appear in the
same scenes but it's kind of implied
that they will based on the prophecy and
the question that's going to be asked
number three the story so Steven Moffat
has said that the story will basically
wrap up all of Matt Smith's tenure all
those running plot threads so there will
be things calling back all the way to
the eleventh hour episode the biggest
part of the story will obviously be the
silence stylist must fall the prophecy
basically says that when the question is
asked no creature can speak falsely or
failed to answer and the reason the
silence we're trying to kill the doctor
during series 6 is because they thought
that he was the only one who knew the
answer to the question basically the
doctor who ? question the interesting
thing about this is that it does imply
that the doctor will have to say his
name out loud his true name obviously in
series 7 during the name of the doctor
he said that that name actually isn't
important than Amy chose
himself is the doctor if you saw the
docudrama an adventure in space and time
William Hartnell is actually one of the
first people to ask at least that we see
on camera asking doctor who ? though it
could be paying off a moment from real
life as well as this big story that's
been running on in Doctor Who number two
the regeneration and the first full
appearance of Peter Capaldi so Steven
Moffat has said that Matt Smith's doctor
number 11 will find regeneration and
death profoundly terrifying and he will
not want to go just like David Tennant
his regeneration into 12 will be just as
traumatizing as tens regeneration in 211
because Matt Smith will regenerate
wearing the same clothes Peter Capaldi
will not have his new outfit until the
first episode of series 8 so we're not
going to see that for basically like
nine months but we do know some things
about series eight and my number one
thing to look forward to in the
Christmas special series eight so
Christmas specials that have involved a
regeneration OST is a little bit of the
tone of what the next series is going to
be but because of the 50th anniversary
we also know some big running plot
threads that just started namely the
search for Gallifrey so like Matt Smith
said during his voice over at the end of
the 50th anniversary episode I've never
known where I'm going but now I do I'm
going home the long way around so
obviously series 8 is going to involve
the search for Gallifrey and it's widely
rumored that Peter Capaldi's run will be
much shorter than Matt Smith's run was
so it could be either one season or two
seasons so it's likely that the search
for Gallifrey will basically end at the
end of Capaldi's run and then series 9
will incorporate the Time Lords into its
stories as well as the stories and
seasons going forward just like classic
who did but let me know what you thought
of the Christmas special teaser
obviously it was only 11 seconds long so
we're going to get a full trailer at
some point they'll have some more
details about what the story's going to
be as well as kind of tease who's going
to be in it the girl and the voice-over
was not Clara so we don't know if Clara
is going to be in the Christmas special
so remember this thursday or friday i'll
be posting that easter egg video for the
50th anniversary and then after that
i've also got a video for my top five
regenerations be sure to subscribe to
get it thank you all so much for your
support during Doctor Who week I hope
you enjoyed the live stream and the 50th
anniversary special as much as I did it
was so amazing right now click here to
get my review of the 50th anniversary
episode and click here to get my review
of an adventure in space and time
they're both amazing everybody go
re watch them right now I'll see you
later tonight high fives
you